alors qu'il espère bien gagner la Coupe
du Monde Cristiano Ronaldo a en tout cas
d'ores et déjà gagné autre chose
Cristiano Ronaldo devient la première
personne à atteindre les 500 millions de
followers
place donc loin devant d'autres
personnalités comme Kim Kardashian et
ses 334 millions d'abonnés
[Musique]
rien que cette année le Portugais obtenu
plus de 100 millions de followers
il faut dire que ces derniers temps le
footballeur fait beaucoup parler de lui
avec notamment cette interview choc où
il s'en prend à son club de Manchester
United depuis que sera l'ex Ferguson est
parti je n'ai vu aucune évolution dans
le club plus de 500 millions de
personnes peuvent donc désormais admirer
Cristiano Ronaldo torse nu faire du
sport avec ses enfants ou encore
réaliser de super placements de produits
sur Instagram
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
ah bah vous voyez mais c'est vrai pour
une publications
moi je pense que la story reste 24
heures
donc c'est un million 600000 € et ça lui
rapporterait par an 40 millions d'euros
est-ce qu'on peut juste dire quand même
qu'on est au maximum de l'indécence en
fait juste c'est si on parle de
quelqu'un qui gagne près de 100 millions
d'euros par an rien qu'en salaire je
parle même pas des autres publicités etc
il passe les 500 millions d'abonnés le
premier truc qu'il a fait c'est de faire
un placement de produit d'une marque de
joaillerie de luxe non mais j'ai rien
contre les influenceurs etc c'est juste
que là on parle de l'une des personnes
les plus riches de tous les temps c'est
pas possible
elle va payer des dizaines de millions
de milliers de dollars pour aller sur un
tapis rouge c'est la loi de la vie faut
mettre en question toute la société
une grande vedette qui fait la pub d'un
parfum une grande marque du café
20 millions il a pris 20 millions
d'euros j'ai un problème
j'ai un problème avec euh j'allais dire
vous savez combien d'argent il ramène à
ses entreprises combien il fait il
permet aussi d'embaucher de payer de
l'emploi
moi j'ai un problème à reprocher de
gagner de l'argent de créer de l'emploi
de créer de l'économie enfin de l'une
des plus grandes marques de joaillerie
qui est de la planète avec les gens moi
j'ai un problème avec les gens qui
regardent dans la poche des autres
constamment ici à chaque fois sur le
plateau parce que je regarde l'émission
souvent vous rentrez dans la poche des
autres les influenceurs les gens qui ils
ont un métier Cristiano Ronaldo c'est un
joueur de haut niveau voilà il a fait
des sacrifices dans sa vie pour
atteindre ce niveau là pourquoi on va
lui reprocher aujourd'hui de jouir de
son activité où il a fait des sacrifices
ou peut-être il a
peut-être mais ils veulent pas son
pognon voilà
parce que il a un salaire monumental
plus des contrats publicitaires
monumentaux je les ajoute son truc
personnel qu'il gère tout seul tu sais
très bien comment ça fonctionne il se
fait des millions en plus des centaines
de millions donc si ça on peut pas
appeler ça pour du café tu crois qu'il
faut que ça gratos que lui mais non mais
tu sais que les niveaux de joueurs
comme des Français qui prennent 1 2 3 4
5 millions d'euros pour des grandes
marques hein
c'est pas ça mais là mais bon en
français
des Français ça s'intéresse de regarder
dans la poche des gens surtout moi
[Applaudissements]
aussi à cette table de nobody
combien vous pouvez donner pour un poste
pour Maxime gaming
170000 aussi
500 euros
c'est quoi le fil ou bien
l'important c'est pas le nombre de
followers
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des je
m'intéresse un peu à ça maintenant ce
que je me dis qu'il y a peut-être un
business à
non mais apparemment il y a des gens qui
ont des qui ont peut-être 30000
followers mais qui sont suivis par des
fans absolus et quand ils vous montrent
par exemple un restaurant un hôtel tout
le monde les retombées sont gigantesque
c'est une excellente influenceuse une
excellente c'est Véronique
elle a beaucoup
que certains et quand elle fait un poste
elle est hyper vendeuse parce que les
gens la suivent ils sont ils adhèrent
quoi en fait
et elle est pas dans mon agence
c'était combien comment j'ai pas entendu
j'ai un secret professionnel
imaginons moi j'ai 7 millions de
followers combien je vends le poste vous
êtes un homme alors ça marche moins que
les femmes
4000 5000 34000 non je te parle de
demander encore Beyoncé
déjà elle en a beaucoup
on va dire que autour de 300000 de
300000 followers on peut vendre quoi
1000 ou 2000 € à peu près
non
d'accord alors regardez quand même parce
que on dit que les mecs c'était les
moins les moins rentables excusez-moi
mais les Cristiano premier
Justin Bieber Benjamin il faut faire une
différence c'est que il y a influenceur
il y a personne suivie c'est pas parce
qu'on est suivi qu'on est influenceurs
et dans ce tableau là je vous garantis
qu'il y aura beaucoup moins de demandes
pour les hommes que pour les femmes il y
a beaucoup plus de demandes pour les
commentaires
dans les 10 les 9 premiers vous me dites
je me trompe mais c'est que des
footballeurs que des hommes alors
je la saisie et là voilà ça c'est en
France vous voyez c'est voilà
Benzema et Pogba
footballeurs jusqu'à la discussion
moi j'ai une petite anecdote sur Karim
alors il faut gentille alors
elle est pas gentille alors non alors
non elle est gentille bien sûr elle est
gentils pour montrer que c'est quelqu'un
de très humble et de très très gentil et
d'accessible aussi c'est un jour j'ai
fait un poste Instagram ou je l'ai
mentionné je me suis dit bon il va avoir
me calculer normal il m'a répondu il m'a
envoyé un message et depuis jour là je
fais que de parler avec lui et
franchement il invite des gens de mon
entourage aussi dans ces soirées etc
super il y a plein d'argent alors Adèle
non j'allais juste répondre à la
question pourquoi Instagram c'est vrai
qu'il y a de plus en plus de marques qui
ont envie de se renouveler aujourd'hui
on le voit avec la publicité classique
il y a de moins en moins d'annonceurs
qui sont intéressés par le contenu
classique donc aujourd'hui il y a des
marques qui préfèrent investir dans
plusieurs micros influenceurs parce
qu'effectivement la micro influence va
susciter plus d'engagement et sur le
long terme ça peut être plus rentable et
comme le disait Magali on va avoir d'un
côté bah les vrais influenceurs qui vont
susciter un achat et on va aussi avoir
des fois comment comment dire bah vous
Benjamin vous êtes animateur influenceur
mais aujourd'hui j'ai un rendement
dégueulasse
c'est pas parce qu'on a un incarnant
qu'on a influence et aujourd'hui on a
les comment s'appelle les créateurs de
contenu qui se différencient encore plus
notamment comme Léna situation comme
poupette qu'on a reçu récemment son
plateau c'est des gens qui suscitent un
engagement colossant de contenu c'est ce
qui s'appelle créateur de contenu parce
qu'ils veulent pas qu'on les
en plus je vous lis quand vous êtes
suivi un peu sur Instagram fait c'est
pas votre métier de faire de l'influence
quand vous faites un poste de temps en
temps on se fait déchirer voilà donc
c'est
légèrement
alors pour pour finir sur le quand même
le Ronaldo il y a la photo dont on ne
sait pas quel a été le montant du
montage il y a une photo entre Léo Messi
et Cristiano Ronaldo pour une célèbre
c'est les remarque qui fait des valises
entre autres et likez alors cette photo
alors est-ce que tu as une maison sur la
photo c'est que les deux ils peuvent pas
se garer
donc ils ont fait la photo chacun leur
coin et après les images
de calendrier Benjamin c'est plus pour
une histoire de calendrier que j'ai dit
une connerie non j'ai dit que c'est plus
pour une histoire de calendrier que
d'amitié ils sont pas amis ils se
déteste pas de ouf
et cette photo elle a été postée samedi
à la récolté 38,4 millions de like je
crois plus de 483000 commentaires on
voit clairement que ces deux
personnalités fortes qui qui donnent
envie de payer pour pour avoir une
communication et pour les jours d'échec
pour les joueurs d'échec il faut savoir
que en fait une partie historique c'est
exactement c'est une partie historique
qui en fait reflète un match nul entre
les deux donc en gros les mises en
situation
c'est pas la première fois que le que
cette marque fait ce type de publicité
parce qu'il y a une quinzaine d'années
ils avaient fait la même chose avec Pelé
Maradona et Zid donc ça avait fait un
buzz il y avait pas les réseaux sociaux
comme aujourd'hui mais ça fait un buzz
là à l'époque ils ont recommencé
photo et dans le top 3 des meilleurs
likes de l'histoire d'installer après
elle a été reprise par tous les plus
grands influenceurs aussi possible